is being the combined authority
returning officer
at the election for the mayor for west
of england combined authority
on thursday 6th of may 2021
certify that the total number of valid
second preference votes
cast for each of the remaining
candidates is as follows
norris dam labour party 41048
williams samuel patrick sutherland the
conservative party candidate
12974 candidates not remaining in the
contest
three four three four four total number
of votes
is eight eight three six six number of
ballot papers rejected is as follows
more than one second preference vote is
given 45
unmarked as the second preference vote
6261
void for uncertainty as to the second
preference vote 38
total number of rejected ballot papers
6299
the total number of valid first and
second preference votes cost for the
of the remaining candidates is as
follows norris dan
first preference 84434
second preference 4104
total one two five four eight two
williams excuse me samuel patrick
sutherland
seven two four one five second
preference
one two nine seven four total eight five
three eight nine i therefore give notice
that dan norris of the labour party
is duly elected as the west of england
combined authority now
[Applause]
dan norris there the labour candidate to
be mayor of the west
of england has managed to take that seat
from the conservatives
and let's have a listen to the winning
candidate can i thank the returning
officer for
the hard work of her and her team i mean
it's been an absolutely phenomenal task
with the pandemic
thank you so much for doing that so well
i know that was a tough job
um obviously i'm most grateful to the
people of the west of england the people
of south gloucestershire of bath of
northeast somerset and bristol
who voted for me today i'm very proud of
our region it's a great region but it
could be even better still
and their endorsement means an awful lot
to me so i thank each and every one of
them for that thank you so much
i also want to thank kia stammer who has
unlocked this election for
labour in the west of england without
him and his skills
and his determination and him being who
he is we could not have got this result
people were able to listen to our
arguments
and be persuaded by them because of kiss
farmers i want to thank him
very very much indeed i also want to
thank my amazing
campaign team i won't name names because
there's so many you've done
wonderful job but you've all worked so
hard in very difficult circumstances
and i'm very very proud of you and what
you've done i hope we will now
up our upper gear and make even greater
inroads in the future
i also want to thank my opponents we've
had a long
candidacy together uh it's been a very
tough
set of um debates that we've had i think
it's 15 in total i think i'm right in
saying and i feel i know them better
than my own family so
i'm looking forward to never seeing them
again at least for a month or two so
uh so anyway but thank you for an
honorable and decent campaign to all of
them
uh they all work very hard and the same
to their workers their work has worked
equally
hard to and and i believe very strongly
that politics is a very noble thing to
do
when people believe in things and give
up their time for free to campaign on
doorsteps whatever their view i have a
great respect for that so thank you to
them too
i think that's pretty much all i want to
say but i am very very grateful for you
waiting so long it's been a long day
i'm sure you'll understand that it's
been a long day for the candidates too
uh and i i'm happy to hand over to
samuel if he's wishing to speak are you
wishing to speak up